Uh Matthew
chapter 4
>> Satan tempting Jesus.
>> Satan kidnapped Jesus. Satan have
kidnapped Jesus. Satan.
>> Yeah.
>> Kidnapping Jesus for 40 days. So I can't
understand what is going on. So
>> I believe that let me explain. Let me
show you why you can't understand
because you don't want to understand.
When Satan saw Jesus, was he a man who
was hungry?
>> Yeah. He's hungry. He's fasting for
>> whether he's only a man or not. When
Satan saw Jesus, did he see a man who
was hungry?
>> Is he a man? Yes.
>> Okay. And he was hungry. So he saw Jesus
as being weak, right?
>> Yes.
>> So unless you think Satan knows
everything,
Satan is looking at Jesus as a man,
hungry and tired. So he thinks that if
he's a man, then he's like all men and
he can be tempted and fall like men do.
And that's where he learned his lesson
because even in that weak moment as a
man who hungered, Jesus was still
greater than Satan. Can I finish over
now? You believe that Jesus is a man?
You believe Jesus?
>> Who said he's not a man? Do you know my
faith? You want me to embarrass? Because
you don't know my faith. Who told you
Jesus is not a man?
>> Jesus is God. You believe Jesus is God.
>> What else do I believe about Jesus?
Finish what I believe. You change the
subject and I'm going to run with you
because I'm going to show you this Jesus
is better than your Muhammad because
Satan got defeated by Jesus. But
according to your Quran and hadith,
Satan bewitched Muhammad, caused him to
fall under magic where your prophet
thought he was screwing his nine wives
and he wasn't touching them. What an
embarrassment. So, thank you for quoting
this because shows that your prophet is
under Jesus's feet because Jesus in his
weakness defeated Satan. But your
prophet came under magic where a Jew put
a curse on him and magic is from the and
then caused your prophet to think he's
having sex and he didn't touch his
wives. So what was your prophet doing?
Playing with himself.
>> I know that hadith that's I know that
hadist. Wait no no run. Don't run.
>> I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm coming. I'm
coming.
>> What was your prophet doing? Can I ask
my question because you're not
answering. What was your prophet M? No.
What was your prophet doing? I'm going
to block you if you don't listen.
>> I want you to finish with Matthew first.
I am finishing. If you listen, what was
your prophet doing when the put him
under magic and he swore he was having
sex with his nine wives like Aisha, but
the wife said he never touched us. Does
that mean he was erect and playing with
himself?
>> Give me give me the number of the of the
hadist.
>> Are you sure? Okay.
>> Yes. Give me give me the number of
hadith.
>> I'm going to give it to you. Hold on.
Come for
[Music]
>> Okay,
>> you you'reing just that you have to
finish.
>> Here you go.
>> Here you go. Can you read it for
everyone? I give it to you here in
private chat. Private chat. Here it is.
Private chat right there. You see the
link? I'm going to open up for everyone.
>> Can I open it up and show it, guys? Here
it is. You want to read it or you want
me to read it?
>> Just give me the number. I know. I know.
Okay, let me read it for everyone so you
don't be scared. Hold on. It's S Bkari
5765.
Let me read it for guys. Jesus defeated
Satan
>> as a man. Who is we? Muhammad had Satan
screw his mind thinking he's having sex.
>> Yeah. Okay. Hold on. Let me show you.
One second. So, I want people to see
that how great your prophet is. I'm
ready to take shahada. Here you go,
guys. Let's open it up.
Okay. You see it, guys? There's the
link. I'm going to read it. You guys got
the link, right? There's the link.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Okay, I'm gonna read it. Okay, you see
it guys? Right here. I'm gonna read it,
guys. Okay, now you explain to me
narrated Aisha.
Magic was worked on Allah's messenger so
that he used to think that he had sexual
relations with his wives while he
actually had not. So he thought he was
having sex with them when he had not.
Sufyan said this is the hardest kind of
magic as it has such an effect. So now,
can you answer the question? What kind
of prophet do you have that Satan played
with his mind, made him think he's
having sex, he didn't touch them? Does
that mean Muhammad saw what looked like
Aisha and got erect and then started
thrusting?
>> Thank you. Thank you. Now I understand.
I understand your point now.
>> Okay. Who's greater? Wait, wait. Who's
greater?
>> Let me let me ask you.
>> Who's greater? One question. Who's
greater? Jesus who as a man weak
defeated Satan or your prophet whom
Satan screwed his mind into thinking he
was having sex. Who's greater?
>> Jesus never defeated Satan.
>> Don't change this question. I'll come to
Jesus divinity. I promise you. If you
want to talk with answer my question.
Who's greater? Jesus as a man who was
weak who defeated Satan and Satan ran
from him or your prophet whom Satan
controlled his mind screwed his mind to
thinking he's having sex. And what was
he seeing that made him think he was
having sex? Who's greater?
>> Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
>> You mean Muhammad whom Satan screwed his
mind? Not Jesus who defeated Satan.
Muhammad's father.
>> Yes. Let's get to the point. Muhammad is
a human beings.
>> But isn't Jesus a human being according
to you?
>> According according to you, Jesus is God
according to you.
>> No. No. According to you, he's a man,
right? So Jesus the man defeated Satan
because you say he's a man. Your prophet
got screwed by Satan.
>> I I I heard that. But our prophet,
>> but you're not answering. So Jesus, the
man, is he better than your prophet?
>> Jesus is not a man according to you.
Jesus is God according to you. I don't
understand.
>> According to you, said he's a man
tempted by Satan. So the man Jesus, was
he better than your prophet? Cuz the man
Jesus defeated Satan.
>> He never defeated Satan. Did Satan
control Jesus's mind to make him think
he's having sex with her? Or did Jesus
resist him, rebuke him, and tell him
Jesus for 40 days? 40 days.
>> And did he defeat him for 40 days or he
succumb like prophet?
>> Jesus is fighting for 40 days. But Satan
Satan for 40 days or did he give in like
your prophet?
>> But the problem is Satan hold Jesus as
hostage for 40 days.
>> No, he didn't. That means you're a Bible
convert. No, because Matthew 4 says it
was Jesus who went into the wilderness
deliberately by the spirit to defeat
Satan. Why are you butchering my Bible?
>> He never defeats.
>> Yes, he did. Matthew 4:1 all the way to
11, Luke 4:es 1 and 12. You're talking
over me. I'm going to send you to Mecca.
>> It says the spirit took Jesus into the
wilderness so he could be tempted by
Satan to defeat him. And did Satan run
from him? Or did Satan control his mind
and make him think he was having sex
like your prophet?
>> Satan didn't didn't run for Jesus. Jesus
called
>> Now, let me let me catch you. You're a
liar. See, you're lying. I quote your
hadith accurately and you're misquing my
Bible. Okay, let's see. When Jesus told
him, "Get behind me, Satan." He left. He
fled. So why you lying, man? Here, let
me show you.
>> Jesus says, "Go away. Go away."
>> And then what happened? So Jesus called
God to help him save him from
>> what happened when he said get behind me
Satan.
>> He's gone.
>> What happened? Here it is. Matthew
4:10-11. See, you're lying about my
book, but I quoted your book accurately.
>> Thank you.
>> Here it is. Let everyone see it.
>> Jesus is gone away. But
>> but Jesus is coming back.
>> Did what?
>> Jesus came back.
>> But did what? Did he run away?
>> He didn't. He didn't run away to him.
Let me read it. I know you're scared.
Then Jesus said to him, "Away with you,
Satan. Away with you, Satan. For it is
written, you shall worship the Lord your
God, and him only you shall serve." Then
the devil left him when he told him,
"Get lost." Now, how come your prophet
couldn't tell Satan, "Get lost." But
your prophet was controlled by Satan.
You still didn't answer that question.
>> Jesus say you should worship the Lord.
>> How do I get there? You change the
subject. for now. Wait, wait, wait. I'm
coming.
>> Change the subject again. Sah, I'm going
to send you to Mecca. Answer my
question. I'll answer yours. I'm going
to show you Jesus is God. He's
worshiped. Stop changing the subject
when I ask you a question. So, I'm going
to give you one more chance. Since you
just saw and you admit Jesus
rebuked Satan, defeated Satan. He ran.
I'm still waiting for the answer. Why is
it your prophet couldn't defeat Satan
and tell him to get lost, but Satan
controlled your prophet, screw up his
mind into thinking he was screwing his
wives and he didn't touch any of them?
Can you answer that? Then we'll go into
Jesus being God. Let's see if you're
going to answer. Let's see if you're
going to answer.
>> I'll give you an answer because our
prophet Muhammad
wasallam, he defeated the never approach
our prophet. He never approached it. So
you mean during that six months to a
year when he's thinking he's screwing
his wives that's a victory
>> and he's thinking he's different he's
thinking is different
>> because it was says because of magic. It
says the magic that the Jew put on him
made him think he's screwing his wife.
So what was he doing? I want to know
okay if there's no one in front of me
why am I going to think I'm having sex.
So, does that mean Satan made Muhammad
see Aisha naked and then Muhammad got
erect and he started doing sexual
positions thinking this is Aisha? I
mean, what a sick prophet.
Can you explain that to me? What made
him think, "Oh, there's Aisha. Let me
jump on her. There's nobody." That means
Satan made him see Aisha who's not there
and made him do things with her who's
not there. So, he's playing with
himself.
>> Okay. Okay. I'm coming. I'm coming.
>> No, no, don't say coming. That's bad.
coming means oh you guys he said I'm
coming your
>> Bible say in Luke
>> so you changed it again you want me to
send you to
>> it's no it's same same subject
>> same point
>> no Jesus was never bewitched and
controlled by magic can you answer the
question
>> inside Luke 22:2
Satan entered Judas and Judas take
control thank you for comparing thank
you for comparing to Judas Guys,
>> he just
like Judas.
>> It's Luke 22:3. You don't know my Bible,
guys. He just compared Muhammad to
Judas. Like Satan entered Judas.
Satan entered Muhammad. Meaning Muhammad
is like Judas. Both of them are sons of
the devil.
Thank you. Judas was of the devil. Thank
you for proving your prophet is of the
devil in hell. Good job. The way deliver
Jesus is the one where deliver.
Okay. Wait, wait, wait. So, you're lying
again.
>> So, did Satan enter Jesus or Judas?
First question.
>> Enter Judas.
>> Second question. Did Satan enter
Muhammad?
Did he control Muhammad like he
controlled Judas? Wait, wait. When Satan
enter Judas, he controlled him to betray
Jesus. Did Satan not control your
prophet to think he was screwing his
wives?
>> Mr. Sam Shamun, you can never finish my
conversation.
>> It's because you don't answer. Okay. You
want to talk about the deity of Christ
now?
>> I said Judas deliver Jesus to be
sacrificed. That means
you want me to send you
a role.
>> Okay, we're back to that again. Judas
betraying Jesus was part of God's will.
Jesus said he lays his life down. No one
takes it away from him. Stop giving me
bad arguments.
The devil having Judas betray Jesus for
Jesus to be killed is something that the
Lord accepted. That's not the same as
the devil entering Judas like he entered
your prophet and made your prophet think
he was screwing women that did not exist
in front of him. Stop. I'm going to
embarrass you.
>> Give me one minute. Can we get to the
deity of Christ because you're wasting
my time now. Can we go to DD Christ?
>> No. No. Nobody's there.
>> What did Muhammad say about Satan
touching all the sons of Adam at birth
except Mary and Jesus? Do you believe
that?
>> You have to let me finish.
>> Do you believe that? I'm going to give
you 10 seconds and I'm going to get you
out of here. According to your prophet
in Bkari Muslim based on the ayah surah
alim 36 it says that Satan the devil
touched every child of Adam when they're
born except Mary and Jesus. Do you
believe that? Do you accept that from
Bkari?
>> I believe so now. So now you believe
>> you admit I want everyone to hear it.
You admit
>> I believe whatever Quran say
>> you admit. Okay, but hold on. So I want
people hear you admit when your prophet
explaining Iran 336 and Bkari Muslims
that the devil touched every child of
Adam except Mary and her son. So you
believe only Mary and his son was not
touched by the devil. Right?
>> Say
>> what
>> what Quran say? I believe
>> it right.
>> I believe again guys notice what it
meant. But isn't Muhammad a son of Adam?
Of course.
>> So, you just admit Satan touched your
prophet when he was born.
>> I I agree.
>> You agree? But he didn't touch Mary and
Jesus. And you still don't see how Jesus
is better than your prophet and your
prophets.
>> He didn't touch touch Jesus and Mary.
>> He touched your prophet, right?
>> He said any son of Adam, any son of man,
>> is not a son of Adam. What is he? A son
of a donkey. Did you not see me? Did you
not see me say
>> Jesus is in 2 Chronicles
18 verse 2022. Even your God is
deceiving men.
>> No, he's not. You're full of it. First
Kings 22 19 and 23 and 2 Chronicles 18
to 22. It wasn't God who deceived. It
was the lying spirit. The same spirit
that appeared to your prophet. So why
are you misquing my Bible?
>> And God and God say go and do so. God
give him
>> because a demon cannot do anything if
God doesn't give him permission. Right?
>> Okay.
>> Wait, stop barking. Chapter 6 verse 112
of your Quran and chapter 19 83 it says
Allah unleashes the on mankind. In other
words, Satan Muhammad's father cannot do
something unless God gives him
permission. So here the lying spirit
could only lie if God gives him
permission. But he's the liar, not God.
But the Quran says your God is the liar.